[MUSIC PLAYING]
Thank you Judy for his
generous introduction.
Because today I actually
have for the first time
the opportunity to talk
about all of the things
that you flagged you
will see Neurath up here.
We will talk about
current settlements,
and we'll also talk
about resistance.
And of course, the
narrative and the lens
through which I
will tell the story
is Margarete Schutte-Lihotzky.
So I want to thank associate
dean Judy Vichniac and Dean
Lizabeth Cohen for
the true privilege
it is to pursue writing
and research here
at Radcliffe Institute.
I also want to thank Associate
Director of the Fellowship
Program Sharon Bromberg-Lim
and Administrator
for Fellows, Rebecca Haley.
I feel that your work really
makes us all feel at home here,
which is wonderful.
One of the amazing aspects
of working here too,
is working with
research partners.
Elizabeth Keto,
Spencer Gillespie,
and Laura [INAUDIBLE]
are all here today.
And I really want to
point out how important it
has been to work together.
Elizabeth's original
and thoughtful feedback
brightens every line
of my ESL writing.
Spencer always reminds me of
the big picture when we cherish
the meaning of small words.
Laura Ty has added sparkle.
She always does that
to presentations.
She literally
illuminates my images.
I also want to acknowledge
the collaboration which PhD
candidate, [? Raphael ?]
[? Kunig, ?] who is here today
as well from the Department
of Comparative Literature here
at Harvard.
And Christiana Bunyan from MIT.
Both of them have been
invaluable in starting
to conceive a translation
project, which is really
something foreign to me.
Finally, I also
want to acknowledge
one of the things that seems
crucial about this fellowship.
And that is the friendships
that have been built here.
So I think that really
needs to be acknowledged
first and foremost.
But here at Radcliffe,
as Judy mentioned,
I've been working on a new
project, a book in translation
project that makes
Austrian architect Margaret
Schutte-Lihotzky's 1985 German
language Erinnerungen aus dem
Widerstand available to
English speaking audiences.
I will only do
this very shortly,
but Schutte-Lihotzky
lived from 1897 to 2000.
So she became 103 years old.
She's arguably one of the
better known female designers
of modern architecture, and
modern architecture commonly
understood of having its
heyday in such institutions
as the Bauhaus in
Germany, though I really
want to resist such
categorizations as you
shall see.
Today, Schutte-Lihotzky
however remains associated
predominantly with
a single work,
that is the design of
her Frankfurt kitchen.
Systematized and rationalized,
the Frankfurt kitchen indeed
became implemented
in 10,000 households
in the city of Frankfurt,
Germany in a vast undertaking
to produce modern
housing in the 1920s.
Yet Schutte-Lihotzky's work life
spans more than eight decades
and includes work as a
designer, as a writer,
and as an activist.
So in the beginning
of this talk,
I want to take a few minute
to discuss the larger
stake of my project and what
Memories from Resistance
raises.
follows Lihotzky's decision
to return to Austria in
1940 from relative safety
in Turkish exile to join
the communist resistance
against the Nazi
regime, as Judy said.
After a month of active
work in January of 1941,
Schutte-Lihotzky was captured
by the Gestapo, together
with the head of the
Communist Party, [INAUDIBLE]..
After her seizure, she spent
more than four years interned
first in Vienna, and then
in a notorious women's labor
camp in Aichach,
Germany where she
was liberated by American
troops in the spring of 1945.
First recorded as a
briefing by Americans
in the summer of
1945, her memories,
which focus on life during
internment in my view,
represent a critical
re-approach to remembering
that offers a glimpse into
the collective practice
of resistance, or what
has been characterized
as quote, "collective
opposition"
to the system in Holocaust
and resistance studies.
The book, I argue, provides
significant records and facts
about the specialization
of sustained dissent,
and the experience of
collectivities of resistance.
And in Schutte-Lihotzky's
case, particularly by women
that defied succumbing to the
reality of totalitarianism.
Hannah Arendt reminds
us about this need
when she writes, quote, "the
conviction that everything that
happens on earth must
be comprehensible to man
can lead to interpreting
history by common places.
Comprehension does not mean
denying the outrageous,
deducing the unprecedented
from precedent,
or explaining phenomena by
such analogies and generalities
that the impact of reality
and the shock of experience
are no longer felt. It means
rather examining and bearing
conscious the burden which
our century has placed on us,
neither denying its existence,
nor submitting meekly
to its weight.
Comprehension in short means
the premeditated attentive
facing up to, and resisting of
reality, whatever it may be."
Schutte-Lihotzky's
work in the resistance
could be understood
in those terms.
In one of the important
passages of the book she states,
quote, "after 1945,
many people, including
some who were in no way
compromised by Nazism,
have asked me why I had
left the relative safety
of my Turkish exile to
come back to Austria.
I am invariably outraged
that they would even think
of asking such a question.
And time and again,
I am appalled
by a world in which
this question can
be a question at all."
So in today's
presentation, I want
to show how thinking
about this need
to face up against
reality, about building
collectivities self-consistent,
and about human solidarity,
have made me reconsider
Schutte-Lihotzky's design
work too.
Although in much
subtler ways, I have
started to see her commitment
to cooperation in the efforts
to create discrete
places of dissent,
particularly for women, through
the production of objects
and architecture in
the interwar period.
And that kind of leads
up to the political work.
And I find relationships between
the experienced solidarity
among political dissidents
and the activism she engaged
in in the women's
and peace movement
aligning her ideas
about translatability
and ending exchange,
and her hopes
for a true internationalism
in the postwar years.
Though in the
discussion today, I
seek to pivot really,
from overspent debates
about kitchens to counterspaces,
to paraphrase colleagues
in the feminist art and
architecture collaborative.
This means discussing
spaces that
were disputed,
challenged, and liminal,
but that also opened up
room for encounter, dissent,
and ultimately, resistance.
And sometimes that did include
kitchens as you shall see.
And in addition, I
want to highlight
that studying the
variety of realms
in which Schutte-Lihotzky
worked, for me, has revealed
moments of uncovering
multiplicity,
local specificity, collectivity,
and attention to the everyday
from within the project
of modern architecture,
and against the claim
that it was aesthetically
doctrinaire, technologically
deterministic, culturally
homogenizing, and
at last, also failed
to deliver on the
social promises
is championed
naively envisioned.
So I want to tell two stories
today about counterspaces
as they were designed,
as they were written,
as they were imagined.
The first, on the
surface about the kitchen
will take us into
where we are now.
And the second one is
about a book manuscript
that on the surface, that
would take us to Beijing
in the post-war years.
So building co-operative
spaces for dissent.
In 1923 Irene Witte, the head
of Berlin's Research Institute
for Labor Science
and Psychotechnology
sent a letter to Margarete
Schutte-Lihotzky.
Quote, "I've worked
through your plans
meticulously, and regard
them as a critical step
in the direction of practical
household rationalization
with the road.
The single law that the
science of home management
has given us, such as time,
and motion efficiency,
and material economy
are adhered to
in the best manner in your
cooking niche and scullery.
I hope that your plans can be
extensively used and realized,
because they would be
able to alleviate somewhat
the housing shortage
we're facing almost
everywhere in the world."
So you see this
cooking scullery she's
talking about here on the left.
The German translator of
American Home Economist,
Christine Frederick knew
housekeeping, Witte, who
was writing, had
helped published
the first substantial text
about efficiency studies
in the domestic realm in 1921.
And for months, Lihotzky
studied Frederick's suggestions
in an effort to design a
small functional kitchen
for a settler house
meant to be realized
in the context of a sell help
building movement in Vienna.
By 1923, the
recites of the study
were on display in Vienna.
And Lihotzky had contacted
Witte for feedback
to improve the design.
So now it was on display, and
she wanted to improve them.
It's really a precursor
to the Frankfurt kitchen.
Witte's comments echoed the
laudatory modernist credo
of functionality
and rationalization
that would only a few years
later become celebrated
in Lihotzky's Frankfurt kitchen.
But proposed in the
context of a citizen driven
building and settlement
movement, the kitchen
and the entire house
is on display in fact,
were more than that.
There were counterspaces.
Spaces that resistance
dominant norms of living.
Lihotzky had come to
the task of designing
for a citizen driven settlement
movement in Vienna in 1920.
Working for a settlement
office whose chief architect
was prominent cultural critic,
the designer Adolf Loos.
The purpose of the
newly founded office
was to create small row houses
for thousands of families
who had formed dispersed
allotment garden
communities during World War
I on the outskirts of the city
to support themselves
through vegetable production.
I should note that
undernourishment
was a contributing cause
to 30% of deaths in Vienna
at the time.
So it was really crucial to
actually farm these allotment
plots.
Lihotzky's first
assignment became
to devise plans
for a co-operative.
Some of them were
wounded veterans
that had squatted on the
former imperial hunting grounds
to build permanent settlements.
And so also bear in mind,
really the appropriation
of these imperial
hunting grounds
really is a distinctive marker.
After 600 years
basically, the arrival
of democracy universal
suffrage that also
puts the Social Democratic Party
in the municipal government
with an absolute majority.
So this is the
political backdrop
against which this happens.
Working from makeshift
at building the row,
Lihotzky and Loos developed
a series of row houses
that considered formal,
but also pressing
social and economic concerns.
From a material
perspective, there
were designed in
wood constructions
and not typical in
Vienna, because it
allowed them to harvest building
materials cheaply and manual
labor on site.
So what you see here is them
actually harvesting the forest
around the grounds where they
had squatted to produce housing
from the harvested wood.
In addition, houses relied
on simplified floor plans
that lend themselves easily
to manual construction
by unskilled and sometimes
impaired workers.
Besides, they also incorporated
allotment parts and row houses,
at least in design featured
espalier fruit to make
the whole building's
facade productive over all,
the design of row houses
followed Loos's principle
that living and sleeping should
be divided on two floors,
and that quote, "the
house should lend itself
to all later possibilities."
So that means it
should be able to be
altered due to family size.
But I should note here that Loos
conceived of these buildings
as predominantly for
families, and predominantly
for families with
multiple children.
Despite the completion of
a row of houses in 1921,
the larger scheme for
the whole facility
was dismissed by the
municipality on the grounds
of being too modern.
And consequently,
settlers [INAUDIBLE]
opted to self build their homes.
And I will bother you with one
architectural detail for a half
minute.
And I won't do any
architecture tricks otherwise.
But that one I want to explain.
So one of the things
that's really important
for them is to create
what are called types.
So the houses become variable
entities of themselves.
So here on the left,
you see a type six that,
towards the facade is
only six meters wide.
And on the right, you see a type
9, that then consequently has
a similar layout, also has
similar building materials,
building elements,
but then it allows
them to create some variety.
And that is important because
it brings down building costs
while not drawing
on industrialization
along the lines, or
kind of standardization
along the lines of industry.
So it can be done
in manual labor.
That is the point.
Then this is the first row
of houses that was completed.
And then the whole
plan of the facility
was dismissed as
being too modern.
But in the absence of a
large scale building program,
settlers took to building
houses themselves, especially
in Lyons, as we can see here.
But the approach of producing
housing with limited material
means and a maximum use
of co-operative labor,
which was abandoned,
was theorized
more proudly and systematized
by Lihotzky's colleague
and good friend Otto Neurath.
An economist, philosopher,
and Austria Marxist Neurath
in fact, unified hundred of
dispersed settlement clubs
in an umbrella
organization in 1921,
and embedded then in a large
tenants and construction union.
Again, a tool to
bring down prices.
He helped create a co-operative
municipal developer,
the so-called GESIBA,
which was charged
with the distribution
of materials
for the production
of settlements.
Again, to bring down costs.
Meanwhile, newly
devised building methods
were implemented citywide with
various sediments cooperatives
fabricating hollow brick
on site in manual labor.
Again, it is distinct choice
against the implementation
of technology.
Henceforth, all settlements
were built cooperatively
with settlers
usually contributing
1,000 to 3,000 hours of the
overall labor process, which
also is said to
have strengthened
their sense of community
in the settlement.
All of these efforts
consciously drew on 20th century
Marxist debates.
Neurath held for example, that
important branches of industry,
such as the
construction industry,
could prepare paths
towards socialization
in the absence of a
fully socialized economy.
But he also envisioned-- and
this is important and kind
of a solid distinction--
that within the
context of scarcity,
cooperatives were
unique organizations
to build use value
centered economies.
So that is what is being tested.
The founding of the
GESIBA in any case,
on a much more immediate
level, provided
Lihotzky with the
opportunity to devise
a new design for
a problem she felt
had remained
unresolved at Lyons.
While working at the
building borough with Loos,
she had observed that
many people in fact,
could not always afford
the required expenses
or even commit the time to
build row houses at once.
So there was really a
problem for certain families
and single people
as we shall see.
But she had that especially
poor seetlers should organize
as cooperatives, be able to
draw on the power of community,
and the services of the
architects they employed.
In 1922, she therefore
designed a minimum settler hut
that provided basic
living amenities,
but could be expanded
to become a full house.
She also helped create
a cooperative band
by hand, a cooperative
furniture store that
provided advice to settlers
and the Viennese public
more broadly.
The outcomes of these
efforts and those
of hundreds of
organizations I should say,
were exhibited in 1923 during
a large allotment garden
settlement and housing
exhibition here,
staged in Vienna City Hall.
The highlight of the show
included seven full scale model
houses, four of them
so-called core houses
designed by Lihotzky.
The core houses could be
built in four distinct phases,
and building elements could
be obtained at reduced rates
through the
co-operative developer.
So for these minimal homes
Lihotzky also designed a first
fully prefabricated kitchen,
which we have seen in the
beginning, type furniture--
that is standard
furniture that also could
be purchased cooperatively.
These services
and amenities were
aligned with the
idea that quote,
"housekeeping and the
habits of residents
are always at the core,
regardless of whether house
is large or small."
This comment naturally
points to Frederick,
and with this work on
household efficiency,
but it also is really a critique
of the modern architecture
that she saw information
in these years.
She followed up on the
statement, noting quote,
"the house must grow
from its inner core
until it reaches its
last, the facade,
not the other way around."
This was a distinct
critique of Loos, too,
who held that these designs
give too much agency to users.
And he really dismissed
them publicly.
Lihotzky then posited that core
houses provided more flexible
living arrangements for people
with a variety of family
circumstances within a
co-operative framework,
including non-nuclear
families, single people,
and young couples, as well
as elderly women, all of whom
had previously been completely
ignored by the settlement
movement before.
Thee gutter here
marks the border
between a core house in
the first stage, which
you see on the right, and a
core house fully built outwards.
So what that really does is, you
start with a tiny, tiny living
kitchen and some
sleeping arrangements,
and then here are some
sleeping on the first floor.
So this is the smallest
unit in the first phase.
And then in multiple phases
you can build outwards,
enlarging the house
with the spaces.
On the bottom here again,
you see the living kitchen,
which was previously this.
So it's now aggrandized, and
with multiple other learning
and sleeping
possibilities here on top.
I also should say
that Lihotzky insisted
that this was only
an emergency measure,
and that it should
not be understood
as an ideal form of living.
So she really worked
hard to overcome
some of these
shortcomings in the larger
houses that were designed.
The close attention to
core houses living kitchen
and a scullery, furthermore
not only showcased attention
to everyday concerns
about housework,
so that is the critique
of Witte and Frederick--
but it proposed
simple design tricks
that could easily be
implemented in every household.
So for example,
all of this, this
is in some way, a precursor
to the other kitchens.
But it pays more attention to
how vernacular kitchens were
built. So in all of the tiny
spaces, storage for wood,
and then in the next
slide we will see here
that, for example, this is a
bath tub that can be warmed up
with fire from below.
And then there's a possibility
to recycle the water
for washing dishes and so on.
So it's really like a
scarcity based approach,
which she also recognized.
The co-operative furniture
store provided services, advice,
and solid designs at small cost.
And it highlighted women
as important bearers
of the cooperative movement,
and Viennese women over all,
it was open to all citizens.
Quote, "how should
people with limited means
obtain good furniture?"
Lihotzky wrote in 1922.
The [INAUDIBLE] is the
cooperative response
to this question.
Architects will devise
new plans for furniture
when settlers and members
of the public need it.
The popular press impressed
core houses at the exhibition.
They lauded them for their
amazingly convenient designs.
The great advantage of the
Austrian Garden City movement
is that houses are being
built by people themselves
for themselves, and
not by contractors
whose first objective is money,
wrote a female journalist
in the [INAUDIBLE].
Otto Neurath, who was a chief
promoter of the core houses
similarly attested that they
embodied the possibility
of alleviating housing shortage,
even in a state of emergency
through large scale
co-operative organization.
He wrote, in severe
times of crisis,
core houses allow for the
construction of small dwellings
to continue according to
plan a series of construction
cooperatives whose building
projects could not be continued
have already begun the
construction of core houses
instead.
Embedded in the larger
cooperative work
that emerged citywide
core houses continued
to build community
and provided services
to marginalized members within
the co-operative framework.
These efforts of building
strong communal and cooperative
economies over all,
I would say can
be understood along [INAUDIBLE]
lines, more or less.
As an alignment of
diverse interests really,
that includes the
power of politicians,
but more importantly the ideas
of a number of institutions,
of community institutions,
of the GESIBA, for example,
grassroots groups,
allotment gardener settlers,
groups of individuals,
and also groups
that have an aligned interests,
such as women's groups
who worked with the GESIBA
and existing stakeholders,
such as tenants, unions,
and leisure groups.
The attention to community
then, the attempt to push
if subtly against
gender boundaries,
and a will to
studying the everyday,
is what I now see in Lihotzky's
further [INAUDIBLE] work.
I'll let this run for a second.
So that is a
cooperative meeting.
You will see that eventually
became a museum that showcased
the achievements of
the settlement movement
within the municipality
of Vienna that's
Neurath explaining the new
settlements to first visitors.
So what does that mean
for the other work?
In Frankfurt, I should
say, Schutte-Lihotzky not
only designed kitchens,
but hundreds of apartments,
among them an apartment
for the single woman.
Also, to add thousands
of women were
homeless at the turn of
the century, single women.
Were also provisioned allotment
garden huts that opened up,
I would argue, a sphere for
women that was completely
detached from the household.
The work in the
Soviet Union, where
she became the head of
an independent design
unit devising
kindergartens, seems
on first sight, relatively
rigidly modernist,
but in time, you do see kind
of an attention in her own work
to habits and vernacular
furniture that she found.
And in Turkey, where she
emigrated with her husband
in 1937, she developed
community centers
and rural educational
institutions,
as well as housing
for migrant women.
After returning
to Vienna in 1945,
the first task she took
on was the provision
of core houses in the
process of reconstruction.
And in a new
position as president
of the Austrian federation
of Democratic Women, that
is the women's organization
within the Communist Party,
you will see that is really
where she finds her foothold.
In terms of power, she
maintains that Austria
had been reconstructed by women
and should not only now fight
for fair wages,
women shouldn't but
hold steadfast
about the attainment
of the post-war years,
neutrality in Austria,
and peace in Europe.
So the question of writing
a sort of humanizing
internationalism.
If that can leads to that.
This book seeks to be only
a small example of how
we can learn from each
other and become closer
on the basis of
professional, scientific,
and artistic interaction
wrote Schutte-Lihotzky
in a book manuscript entitled
Million Cities in China
in 1956.
The book was an
attempt, as she noted,
to encourage European
architects to learn
from the immense undertakings
in city planning then underway
in the People's Republic.
Schutte-Lihotzky collected some
of those materials for the book
during a five-week study
excursion to China in 1956,
on the invitation of the Chinese
Society for Cultural Relations
Abroad.
Overall, the group was
composed of scientists,
social scientists, artists,
and a humanist, seven men
and two women.
And Schutte-Lihotzky was invited
for her role as architect,
but also the head of the
Federation of Democratic Women,
so within the Communist Party.
This opportunity to
study Chinese cities
was a unique
professional opportunity
to be sure in the
realm of architecture
for Schutte-Lihotzky
at this time.
In fact, finding
regular employment
in architecture in
Vienna was no small task
in the post-war years.
Other colleagues were joining
the ranks of the Viennese
municipality as city
architects, advancing
despite and because of
their age and experience.
But against the backdrop
of Cold War divides,
the Viennese
municipality was varied
to employ a female communist.
Former Nazis, still
in positions of power,
ostracized Schutte-Lihotzky
from the architectural community
for which she longed.
By the early 1950s,
the only position
that produced steady
work was the role
in the Federation
of Democratic Women
whose elected president
she'd become in 1947.
This work allowed her to
travel and to envision herself
as a political
organizer, but also
as an architectural
critic, a role
she admitted she felt
quite uncomfortable
with to become a writer
and a critic to comment
on other people's work.
In writing about cities
and urban life in China,
she could draw on some
previous, but very modest
architectural experience.
Schutte-Lihotzky had in fact,
already traveled to China
for two months in 1934,
so 22 years prior,
on the invitation of a Chinese
educational delegation working
for the nationalist government
on the Chiang Kai-Shek
and the Kuomintang,
famously later
to retreat to Taiwan with
the seizure of Beijing
by the Communist government.
The delegation had
encouraged Schutte-Lihotzky
and her husband,
Wilhelm Schutte,
then working in
the Soviet Union,
to move to Nanking to apply
their respective expertise
school and kindergarten
to sign in the context
of an expansive educational
modernization program.
While the couple declined to
work in the Republic of China
permanently in 1934, I would
assume for political reasons,
they agreed Schutte-Lihotzky
would establish guidelines
for the design and
construction of kindergartens
and public nurseries.
And to present those
during the expanded trip.
Over several weeks
in May of 1934,
she traveled with the
trans-Siberian railway
from Vladivostok to Tokyo, and
then from Shanghai to Beijing.
Then to the capital Nanjing,
Hangzhou, and [INAUDIBLE]..
Aside from meetings with public
officials and giving lectures,
she visited numerous
educational facilities
across the Republic
of China, including
already existing modern
schools and cities, as well as
temple schools, where most
children in rural regions
receive primary education.
In the guidelines
later submitted,
Schutte-Lihotzky
was adamant really,
without questioning her
role as a foreigner engaged
in a vast developmental
undertaking,
that no matter if an
urban or rural site,
it was crucial to create
spaces for small groups
of children, even in a
large kindergarten, at least
with one pedagogical staff.
So there is really kind
of a sort of homogenizing
of the design principles.
She also gauged the
success of the construction
of kindergartens
based on the degree
of achieved systematization,
so firmly in line
with what other modernist
would have argued.
Quote, "Dear Minister of
Education Wong Shing,"
she wrote to one of the high
ranking officials in Nanjing,
"after visiting
many kindergartens
in various cities, I have
come to the conclusion
that it will be
necessary to review
the question of the
organization, construction,
and establishment
of kindergartens
in the near future,
and systematically
work through design schemes.
This thorough systematization
should ideally
be carried out in
the current state
at a time when kindergartens
are constructed on a vast scale
throughout the country become.
Only through
systematic execution
of all fundamental
preparations with development
of kindergartens with
the existing means,
be truly economical."
Also, there is an underlying
question of systematization
and economics.
But in crucial junctures,
she veered away
from such assertions
of design expertise.
She existed for example,
that local architect
knowledgeable about
diverse regional building
techniques and existing
building typologies
should need all
projects, especially
if kindergartens and nurseries
were conceived as types.
So again, it goes back
to the systematic design.
They should be attuned
to climatic conditions.
And this is really important
because it's different.
It's not only about
technology and environment.
It's about customs and culture.
Quote, "the old locally
customary construction,
which is open to nature, but
protect spaces from the sun,
will have to form the basis
of the architectural design
without copying previous
styles," she wrote.
Likewise, it is necessary to
avoid copying and importing
European and American styles.
Rather, it is necessary
to try to create
with existing and
climatic conditions means,
materials, and
construction methods,
together with the
experiences of Europe
and American building types
that document the free spirit
of future generations of China.
This attention to not only
climate and technology,
but culture and
history, is noteworthy
because it was not at the
impetus of other modernist
at the time.
Loos had held that
improvement was never
warranted where time
and custom had already
found a sufficient
solution, but only
when technical progress had
found a more convincing answer.
But Schutte-Lihotzky's
view of this idea
extended to forms
of translation.
And a cherished cultural
customs, social life,
and everyday practice.
As we shall see, I think
there are also limits to it.
In photos indeed,
she try to gain
insight about the variety
of existing kindergartens,
but also the everyday lives
of children and young people.
She studied
vernacular children's
furniture, existing play
structures, and landscapes
inhabited by grandfathers,
mothers, and kids.
While documenting the immense
artistic achievements of China,
she also created a
series of images,
recording quotidian
domestic architecture.
She paid attention
to urban street
life, as well as
landscapes, and how
people organized
their daily lives
in cities and in rural regions.
She documented working
conditions of urban workers,
and those in the country,
and the role of the young
and the elderly in the
production of housing.
Overall she was interested
in the elements and objects
that shaped everyday life,
and how these elements
could potentially reconcile
modern and traditional
lifestyles.
I do think there are really
some problematic aspects here
that call to mind the long
entanglements of photography
and Orientalism.
And I would really like
to discuss that in the Q&A
if you have thoughts.
But I also want to
acknowledge that there
is an overarching narrative
of Chinese achievement
and progress that underlines
the produced documents,
and in particular,
the book manuscript.
In fact, in the second trip to
China 22 years later in 1956--
and both of these trips
become combined for the book--
the issue of modernity's
relationship to tradition
became a question of
urbanism at large.
Previously it was about
objects and architecture.
Visiting Beijing, Nanking,
Shanghai, Gansu, and Wuhan,
Schutte-Lihotzky's
photographs now
depict a distinct story of
Communist progress, political,
economic, and cultural,
doubtlessly also shaped
by the organization of
the trip, that pointed
to vast modernization efforts.
But this is also
really hard doing.
Over six weeks, the group
visited construction sites
and large infrastructural
developments,
research extraction
plants, coal, petroleum.
Additional trips
included meetings
with party officials
and municipal officials.
Here, there were multiple
meetings with housing officials
in Beijing.
Schutte-Lihotzky
also met [INAUDIBLE]..
Aside from documenting these
encounters, what is recorded
is rapid modernization, and
the production of new housing
a cultural, educational,
scientific institutions.
Once again, she spends
considerable time
studying spaces for
children, but now
in a large cultural
institutional network
that includes schools,
hospitals, factory nurseries.
She did those
modernization efforts
with prefabricated elements
and traditional construction
techniques.
But what she also does-- and
I think that is something
in the future work that I
would like to theorize a little
more--
she translates modern
and traditional
architectural
vocabularies into what
she sees as this unique form
of language to has emerged.
Having studied the
colonial oppression
by Western powers
in China, admittedly
through a distinctly communist
lens, Schutte-Lihotzky by 1956,
now is careful to point to
China's intrinsic history
of modernization.
And twelve lectures
after the trip,
and in the eventual
book manuscript,
she arrives at a thesis, if
not completely made explicit,
that China had always
been modern, and thus,
unique position to reconcile
tradition and modernity.
That is what she
writes in the book.
Tall walls are part and
parcel of Chinese urbanism,
but they were not
zigzagged garrisons.
So she actually
kind of compares it
to European history, which
she dismisses, but perfectly
perpendicular orientation
systems that regulated
and systematized the
interior life of the city.
Domestic architecture, she
adds in the written account,
follows the pattern
on a smaller scale.
The courtyard topology of
the domestic architecture
of the hutongs allows for
social and communal life
to grow and reinvent
itself over generations.
And she provides a
number of design schemes
where she seeks
to understand how
families grow within the
constraints of the hutongs.
Being distinctly urban,
it sheaths the family
from public view, while allowing
people to shape the city.
In the eventual
book manuscript, she
considers Beijing's urban
domestic architecture--
the hutongs-- it's
kind of sort of types.
These types, she
says however, had not
arrived in the present at the
hand of a number of architects.
But they had
developed over time,
based on the ingenuity of
designers, of craftsmen,
of builders, and inhabitants.
So it really supersedes
what she feels
they had achieved in all
the previous employments.
They are extensive
and significant works
of art historians and Chinese
architecture and specialized
literature, she writes
in the introduction
to Cities of Millions in China.
But there are hardly
any works written
from the point of view of the
architect or the city planner,
who today has to make decisions
about the future development
of big cities.
Work that shed light on
urban planning, but also
the way of life of Chinese
people, in the context
of current social and economic
realities, in the context
of rapidly advancing changes
in social life, in the life
of women, of families,
and in the context
of great industrialization.
In short, with the
current transformation
of the entire country.
However, this is
especially necessary
if one wants to have an overview
of the task of urban planning,
and to do so in such a
way that these views can
be instructive and fruitful
for our work in Europe.
It has previously been remarked
that Schutte-Lihotzky somewhat
naively believed in both the
transformational potentials
of Communist ideas, even as
the limits became more clear.
It's important to keep in
mind that the manuscript was
completed in 1956.
A unique moment five years
after the Communists and Mao had
ceased power, but
two years before
what is still euphemistically
called the Great Leap Forward,
and more than a
decade before the peak
of the cultural revolution.
So Schutte-Lihotzky
found herself
in an already radically
altered politically altered
China, but in which some
of the repressive extents
were not completely known.
It is estimated that during
the Great Leap Forward,
alone 50 million people were
killed or died from starvation.
That is not even to speak of
forced rural collectivization,
which did exist when
Schutte-Lihotzky visited
in 1956.
So we might ask
the question, how
somebody who resisted
totalitarianism
accepted the normalization
of dehumanisation elsewhere.
So in conclusion,
I want to offer
three final thoughts on
this last contradiction, not
answers, but maybe
more questions.
What kind of resistance?
And also what kind
of solidarity?
What kind of feminism
can we see here?
At least since the publication
of feminist Marxist analysis,
such as Nicole Cox and
Silvia Federici's essay
Counter Planning from the
Kitchen Waitress for Housework,
it has become clear that
especially the most lauded
aspects of Schutte-Lihotzky's
work in architectural history
has been criticized.
They write without
very much in 1977,
that schools,
nurseries, and day cares
have taken away from mothers
much of the socialization
of their children, and that
the decrease in house size
and the mechanization
of housework
has meant that the housewife
is potentially left
with much greater leisure time.
So that has been dispelled
that that is not true.
Yet I think I've
tried to argue here
that architecture history
has until now, really
incorrectly overemphasized
rationalization and tailorism.
And it's kind of
been my attempt here
to show that the spaces and
services that Schutte-Lihotzky
helped build first in a
co-operative framework,
encouraged the advancement of
women within that framework,
encouraged solidarity.
Cox and Federici
acknowledged such aspects
within their fury
of wage struggle
when they write, quote, "wage
struggles take many forms,
and is not confined
to wage raises.
Reduction of work time and
more and better social services
are wage gains."
But they also acknowledge
that only wages for house work
really opened up a perspective
of conceiving quote,
"women's work in the
home within the struggle
of the overwhelming majority
of the world's population,
millions of women and
men in fields, kitchens,
prisons who are wageless.
So, solidarity, how can we know
other structure in the world?
In his Pedagogy
of the Oppressed,
Paulo Freire
provides ideas that I
find useful in discussing
the question of solidarity.
When he says persons
should not be
afraid to confront, to listen,
to see the world unveiled.
But he continues, so the person
is not afraid to meet people
or to enter into
dialogue with them.
He does not consider himself
the proprietor of history
or of men or the liberator
of the oppressed,
but he does commit
himself within history
to fight at their side.
He adds, while both
humanisation and dehumanization
are real alternatives, only the
first one is man's vocation.
Which brings me back to our rant
and the question of resistance.
Here, I have to admit that
the diagram I showed you
in the very beginning of this
talk that women in internment.
It set quite
uncomfortably with me
for a long time because of
it's innocuous appearance.
It felt normalized.
But today, I think
it indeed does
perform another type of labor.
It is to normalize I think not
oppression, but resistance.
[APPLAUSE]